This episode is brought to you by curiosity stream,
a subscription streaming service that offers over 2000 documentaries and
non-fiction titles unlimited access starting at just two 99 a month in 30 days
for free. If you sign up through the link below and use the code,
biographics more on them in a bit.
Pull the Persian Kings Xerxes is probably the one best remembered today.
Thanks to his battle with 300 brave little Spartans,
which allowed him to enter the public consciousness in a more broader sense.
He is known for his invasion of mainland Greece,
which went much further than the military campaign of his father Darious.
He saw it as a duty to fulfill his father's mission of punishing the Athenians
for their involvement in the Ionian revolt. In that regard,
he can be considered successful seeing as he conquered and pillaged Athens,
even though Xerxes was ultimately unable to retain his control over Greece,
and he have to retreat back to Persia defeated.
His reign also marks the last period of dominance for the argument at empire
afterwards,
the empire power slowly started to fade it's conquering days were over,
and most of its efforts were focused on keeping the lands that already had until
the inevitable day when it collapsed completely under the might of Alexander the.
Reach.
Or Kashi Yar, if you want.
The Persian name was born circa 518 BC as the first son of Derrius.
The great ruler of the Academy at empire and his wife Atossa who was also the
daughter of Cyrus, the man who founded the Persian kingdom. And by the way,
we've already done biographics on both Darrius and Cyrus.
If you haven't seen them,
please do check them out to get a better understanding of the Persian empire.
And also because Xerxes is rain picks up where Derrius is ended in his fight
with the Greeks. Just to give you a quick recap, ever since the time of Cyrus,
the R Kevin and empire included Greek city States located not in Greece, proper,
but on the coast of Asia minor, modern day Turkey.
Oftentimes these cities were not actually part of the empire,
but were ruled by tyrants who were named as buy-ins completely subservient the
Persian King in 499 BC. However,
these cities revolted against Derrius with the help of a few mainland Greek city
States. Most notably Athens, eventually Derrius managed to quell the rebellions,
but he also swore vengeance on the Greek city States that provided aid.
And that is how the first Persian invasion of Greece started in 492
BC. The invasion ended in defeat, even though Daria has had the early advantage,
the Persian expedition failed following a decisive Athenian victory at the
battle of marathon in 490 BC. This is not the turndown area.
So you started planning a second invasion immediately,
except that this time he would lead us troops, personally,
something he was unable to do the first time due to his failing health.
His plans were put on hold though, due to another revolt this time in Egypt,
he intended to deal with both problems,
but he died in 486 BC before solving either one.
So his successor would have to pick up where he left off.
Obviously we all know that Xerxes then became the new King of the acumen at
empire, but he did have some competition.
Strictly speaking Xerxes was not Derrius. His oldest son.
He was the oldest son since Derrius took power. And more importantly,
he was the son of a tosser who had the blood of Cyrus, the great in her veins,
but Daria has had three other sons by a different wife before he became a King
of them.
The oldest was [inaudible] and he argued that as the eldest child of Darious,
he deserved to be King Derrius himself was not sure what to do.
And he took counsel strangely enough, from a Greek, not just any Greek,
but a former Spartan King named [inaudible],
who was forced to flee his native land and received a sign of in Persia.
The Spartan advised Daria's taking the side of Zak seasoned,
arguing that [inaudible] would not have the Royal prerogative because when he
was born, both him and his father were still communists.
Derrius was in agreement and named Xerxes to be his successor.
All of this information comes to us courtesy of well, who else,
but good altar us.
And he personally Pines that even without [inaudible] intervention,
Derrius was still likely to put Xerxes on the throne due to the power and
influence of a tosser. So sometime in late 486,
BC axes became the new King and his Ascension. When smoothly,
without any challenges,
he then wrote down the fact in a famous inscription to set the record straight
safe. Zach sees the King, other sons of Derrius. There were thus,
or who remaster was the desire Derrius.
My father made me the greatest after himself.
When my father Derrius went away from the throne by the will of RMS,
I became King on my father's throne.
[Inaudible].
He's ruled over the Academy at empire.
He has important matters to attend to the Greeks would have to wait as fast.
That was the matter of the Egyptian revolts.
This did not prove overly difficult.
Zach's he's already had an army at the ready as his father mustard.
It an anticipation of going to war against Athens.
We do not have too many details about this military campaign,
but the Persian King was able to put down the rebellion in a single expedition
in 485 BC. He was much harsher with his conquered foes than his predecessors,
imposing ruthless punishments on the Egyptians and leaving his brother.
Our Kemeny is behind to govern the province. The following year,
there was another rebellion this time in battle on led by a man named Belle
Shamani again, Xerxes marched his army and put down this uprising.
And just a matter of weeks, two years later in 482 BC Babylon rebelled,
once more under Shemesh Ariba who declared himself the new King,
although this revolt was also defeated,
it proved more durable than the first one and required a months long siege of
the city.
Ancient sources tell us that Xerxes was severe in his punishment of Babylon and
ended the special relationship.
This one's great embar had with the Persians up until that point,
ever since it had been conquered by Cyrus,
Babylon was regarded as one of the recommended empires,
greatest possessions through always use the title King of Babylon and
inscriptions and to the Persian King also took part in Babylonian religious
rights, every new year,
by traveling to the city to take the hands of the statue of Marduk Babylonian,
God placed inside the city's main temple. The ESSA Gila,
this all ended under seas, he and the temples pillaged,
and allegedly even removed the statue of Mada and brought it to Persia to be
melted down since then.
He also no longer use the title King of Babylon and inscriptions instead
referring to himself as King of the Persians and the Medes.
Now there's all the internal strife was dealt with.
It was finally time to take on the Greeks or was it classical sources like
Rhonda does made Xerxes zone to be very undecided regarding the path he should
take. We cannot say how accurate this portrayal was,
but it indicated that the King alternated at least three times between war and
peace at first Xerxes wanted war mainly persuaded by my donors, his cousin,
and his, one of his closest allies.
His arguments were that the Greeks had to be punished for what they did to the
Persians,
but also the Greek mainland rich and beautiful lands worthy of no
mortal master.
But the King decided Xerxes held in assembly with all his Nobles and told them
of his plans. He said for myself, ever since I came to this throne,
I have taken thought how best I shall not fall short in this honorable
place of those that went before me.
And my thoughts persuades me that we may win not only renown,
but a lands neither less Norwest, but more fertile,
which we now possess for this.
Cause I have now summoned you together that I may impart to you my purpose.
It is my intent to bridge the hell spawns and take my army through Europe to
Hollis that I may punish the Athenians,
what they have done to the Persians and to my father.
He is dead and it was not granted him to punish them and die on his and all the
Persians behalf will never rest till I have taken and burnt Athens for the
unprovoked rock, but it's people did to my father and me, my daughter has again,
spoke up to applaud the King's decision.
The other nobleman required except for an uncle of Xerxes named art Abana who
advised him to reconsider years prior. [inaudible]
had told dairies the same thing when he wanted to go to war against the Syrians
and now's axes wanted to do the same against a much more powerful foe.
An army made up of the most doubty warriors by sea and land.
The King was greatly angered by art Abana saying that it was only because he was
his father's brother, that he escaped punishment for his insolence.
It seemed that Xerxes had made his decision,
but that night had a vision which caused him to change his mind.
And the next day he claims that he would not March against Greece and instead
would abide in peace.
But then the next night he had another vision which offered Xerxes.
He's a prophecy saying that if he did not lead his army armies,
the things that made him great and mighty would disappear and he would be
brought low. Again,
this vision so greatly frightened the Persian King that he went to his uncle,
Audubon us to tell him about it and then ask him to wear the Royal robes and
sleep in the Royal bed the adviser did. So,
and it's the same prophetic dream came to him wanting again of terrible things
that would before Zach sees, if he did not go to walk.
And so finally autobalance himself changed his mind.
And from then on the Persian King became intense on invading and conquering
Greece. And look, if you're enjoying today's video,
well then let me tell you about today's sponsor,
who I think you will also enjoy.
Curiosity stream is a subscription streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and non-fiction titles from some of the world's best filmmakers,
including exclusive originals. Now, if you're enjoying this video,
if you're enjoying biographics in general, to be honest,
then why not try out curiosity stream and check out one of the number of
documentaries about history's greatest empires. Look, if you liked this video,
you're going to like that as well. Just go over to that platform,
punch in empire or empires, whatever you like.
And a lot of options are going to populate for you.
You will find something that you will enjoy.
Curiosity stream is available on many platforms, web app, Roku, Android,
X-Box one spot TV, iOS, Chrome cost, Amazon fire, Amazon Kindle, and Apple TV,
and it's available worldwide. So none of that geo restriction nonsense,
you get unlimited access starting at just two 99. And for you guys,
the first 30 days are completely free. Just sign up through the link below,
use the promo code biographics and you'll be good to go.
It's a great way to support the show,
keeps me making more videos and I couldn't think of a better fit for sponsorship
than curiosity stream for this channel. And let's get back to it.
Evenly Xerxes have finally made up his mind.
He did not charge headfirst into battle. Instead he spent years in preparation.
The initial challenge was simply getting degrees in one piece. First,
the army had to cross from Asia into three spike traversing,
the Dardanelles straits known back then as hell spawns.
According to her auditors,
Xerxes the Egyptians and Phoenicians built two bridges that connected to solders
the former capital of Lydia to another city named Abbott dos on the other side
of the street. However,
those bridges were broken and swept away by a furious storm. So great.
It was the anger of the King when he found out that he not only had the builders
executed,
but also ordered his men to give 300 whip lashes to the hell spont itself,
and to drop a pair of manacles into the water to symbolize this.
Even the sea itself, must've be the will of his axes. Afterwards.
He had two pontoon bridges built, which proved to be sturdier and more reliable.
Nan's in 480 BC, the Persians crossed the street into Europe in three,
the army went two ways part by lands and part by CAEP. However,
Xerxes was careful to avoid a lethal mistake made by one of his father's
generals. During the first invasion of Greece athlos was not a launch peninsula,
but the waters around it were treacherous. So when the fleet went around, it,
it was caught in a storm and destroyed to avoid having the same thing happened
to him.
Xerxes ordered his men to build a canal through the Smiths that connected the
peninsula to the mainlands. Obviously over the course of millennia,
the Xerxes canal was completely buried in sediments,
but it was actually found recently using aerial photography.
There remains one of the few traces of the invasion of European soil,
but it also serves as a nice reminder that I rather just occasionally knew what
he was talking about. And speaking of heroic,
the historian claims that the army assembled by Xerxes was the largest in
existence. Unlike anything the world had seen before,
it contains soldiers from all over Asia of 30 different ethnicities.
And that did not take into account the numerous three Sian tribes that Xerxes
encountered on his way to Greece,
which were added to his numbers either willingly or by force. However,
we cannot provide you with an accurate figure is the size of the army is still
hotly debated.
And the estimates are all over the place from a few hundred thousand soldiers as
proposed by modern scholars to a few million based on ancient sources,
either way. This was an army that no Greek city state hoped to take on loan.
The Greeks, however,
had not been dawdling this whole time ever since they repelled the first Persian
invasion under Darrius,
they knew it was only a matter of time before a new one would come the Athenians
in particular, who was Xerxes main targeted,
but in busy building up their fleet for an unrelated war with another city state
names, uh, Gina, however, in 481 BC,
when they heard that the Persian army was on the move,
dozens of Greek city States held a council in Corinth and decided to put aside
all their feuds and deal with this major threat.
Many other cities States wanted no part of it.
So instead paid tribute to Xerxes when he sent forth ambassadors,
asking for earth and water,
hoping that his issues with Greece would not involve them.
Only two city States were never given this option because the axes admitted them
from the start. Those States were Athens and Sparta.
Hello.
480 BC, [inaudible] out his first major encounter.
And then this is the famous one that everybody has heard about the battle of
Thermopylae,
where 300 Spartans led by King Liana dis staged a daring lost stand fighting
bravely to God.
The coastal pass of the marbly also called the hot Gates in the ends of the
varsity superior numbers of the Persian army proved too much to overcome.
And all the Spartans fell in battle. If you're familiar with this event,
it's probably because of the movie 300 or the comic book series,
it was based on however,
those two helped create a few prevalent myths about the battle of the marbly.
And we're not just talking about showing Xerxes as a seven-foot giants with a
thing for gold piercings. Undoubtedly,
the biggest myth is that the 300 Spartans were there alone. In fact,
they weren't not even close.
The Spartans might've been in charge of the defense,
but they were joined by about a dozen other Greek groups, including thespians,
DBMS Arcadians and fissions syncytial.
There were around 6,000 to 7,000 Greeks at the battle of Thermopylae as to the
Persians, but we don't know a lot more than that.
Certainly as a Roger just claims that just their casualties number 20,000 men,
a crucial role in the basket was played by FLTs.
This was the spot and who betrayed his people and told Zach seas of a secret
trail that allowed his soldiers to flank the enemy.
It was actually real that he was not a to form spot and he resented his
compatriots because he could not fight alongside them.
He wasn't despising at all. In fact,
he was part of a Greek group called the Malawians,
who lived in the city state of trackers. Lastly,
a lot of sources mythologized this battle and portrayed the Greeks is willingly
undertaking a suicide mission where they knew from the start that they had no
chance of winning. Again,
this is not true if there were truly only 300 Spartans, maybe,
but it would have made absolutely no sense to sacrifice a whole army of 7,000
soldiers for no reason.
This is evidenced by the fact that once the Greeks realized that the Persians
were flanking them, most of their remaining forces retreated,
that is when Liana does and to Spartans decided to stay behind and form a rear
guard in order to give everyone else time to escape.
They still were not alone though.
The thespians and the oceans also stayed behind to fight.
So they deserve some credit to the Thebans also stayed,
but eventually surrendered finally, well, this is not a myth.
It is an important aspect that is often forgotten while the land's battle at the
monopoly was going on.
The Greeks and the Persians were simultaneously engaged in an important Naval
conflict known as the battle of Artemisium.
The bulk of the Greek forces was provided by Athens,
since they have the strongest fleet aided by Corinth McGarrah, uh,
Gina chock is Sparta and others.
The battle was not a crushing defeat for the Greeks like the monopoly,
but they still were able to stop the advance of the Persians following these two
encounters Xerxes to gain control over the regions of Ebola,
but we share and focuses. And most importantly,
he had a clear route to Attica where Athens was located in September 480 BC
Xerxes ended Athens, the city had been mostly abandoned with the seniors,
fleeing to a Gina and Solomon,
just a few remains to try and protect the Acropolis,
but they were easily defeated. So actually it was,
was finally able to fulfill the Val first made by his father to punish the
Athenians for their interference in the Ionian revolt always two decades prior.
Yeah, the city burns and pillaged Athenian,
symbols like Pantheon and the temple of Athena were raised to the ground.
Although these would be rebuilt a few decades later by paraklete is bigger and
better than ever.
Well, everything seemed to go in Xerxes favor.
All the remaining Greek forces have gathered on the Peloponnesian peninsula in
the South of Greece,
which on foot could only have been accessed by crossing the narrow isthmus of
Corinth. However,
the Greeks took steps to ensure this would not happen as they destroyed the only
roads and directed a wall in its place.
It was actually his work to continue his conquest of Greece.
It would have to do it by water strategically.
It would have been wiser to wait out the Greeks by creating a blockade,
to surround their Navy concentrated around Salomon.
Since he went out each group of people to slowly disband and return to their own
cities. In fact,
one of the Persian Kings allies queen Artemisia or of carrier advised him to do
just this, however, his other generals, and indeed Zach sees himself.
We're sure a victory with one giant show of force at sea after all his fleet was
bigger, consisted of better ships. And at the tactical advantage,
the battle of Solomons took place sometime in late September 480 BC.
And it was a shocking and brutal defeat for the Persians that completely turned
the tide of the campaign in favor of Greeks.
Unfortunately none of the classical sources gave a detailed account of the
battle. So we don't know what bold and brilliant military strategies,
the Greeks employed to secure the unlikely victory.
I wrote it just mainly credits this country,
men for being orderly and determined while the Persian army was much more
chaotic and disorganized,
which she sees as the reason that they should come to suction and,
but fell them to illustrate his point.
He tells the story of the AFA mentioned autumn Mysia,
who while being chased by an Athenian trireme around and destroyed a friendly
ship to convince her pursuers that she was on their side.
The vessel she sang got on board,
the King of calendars who died in the water and other early casualty at the
start of the battle was Aria, big knees,
a brother of [inaudible] and the Admiral leading the Phoenician fleet whose
death caused a lot of panic and loss of morale among the Persian Navy died gives
lots of credit to the Athenians for the role they played in the victory,
which is not surprising considering they accounted for over half of the entire
Greek fleet.
Also noteworthy with the McGarry ones and the Agon nations who were considered
the best seaman off to the Athenians and alone informs the right-wing of the
Greek forces. The location of the battle also played an important role.
The passage inside the Strait of Salem,
this was too narrow for the advancing Persian line,
which had to withdraw ships and reorganized mid battle,
thus leading to the general chaos and confusion, which ended in their downfall.
This shocking, upset, forced Zach seas to completely reconsider his next move.
He did not want to spend the winter in Greece and then another season
campaigning while neglecting the rest of his empire.
He also feared that the Greek Navy might make its way up North and destroy the
bridges. He had built across the health bonds,
thus trapping his land army in Europe.
Therefore he decided to take a large part of his army and to make his way home
leaving his elite infantry and his cavalry under the command of his general,
Mar Donius to keep the pressure on in mainland Greece.
This strategy did not end well for the Persians after winter passed,
they were on the warpath again,
but so were the Greeks who had time to reorganize and strengthen their forces.
The Greek army mainly consisted of Spartans, Athenians and Corinthians.
Although over a dozen other cities also contributed soldiers.
The two sides match at the battle of potassium sometime during the summer of 479
BC. Again,
it was a triumphant victory for the Greeks decisive enough that it drove the
Persians away from the Greek mainland's at the same time,
the Greek fleet made its way to Asia minor to execute a preemptive strike on the
remaining Persian Navy station that instead of a Naval vessel,
the Persians coerced the Greeks into coming on lens.
But this tactic was in vain at the battle of Mikael,
the Greeks beloved a final crushing blow to their opponents effectively ending
the Persian invasion afterwards,
the Spartans and the rest of the Peloponnese sailed home,
considering their mission, a success,
the Athenians and other city States pressed on with a counter attack to liberate
the Greeks in Ionia as well.
[Inaudible].
Tell how Xerxes perceived his military campaign in Greece.
Obviously it didn't end like he wants it, but he did accomplish his stated goal,
which was to punish Athens.
It would have been possible for him to rebuild his army and try again in a few
years. But from that point on, he seems more concerned with internal matters,
ensuring that he maintains control over his possessions in the middle East and
Northern Africa. He also became a prolific builder during this time,
mainly in Persepolis and Susa.
He completed the unfinished projects of his father and started his own the app
and Donna, the gate of all nations. That's a cholera palace, the Citadel,
the gardens, the canals of Persepolis.
They were all finished during the 15 years that followed Xerxes did have one
last attempt in 466 BC.
When he tried to regain control of the Ionian States in Asia minor,
if he had succeeded, he would have likely considered a third invasion,
but he was defeated at the battle of Euro medium by a Greek Alliance,
known as the deli and league.
And he gave up whatever plans that he might've had,
even if he did intend on a new invasion,
he would not have had the opportunity to go through with it because he was
assassinated the following year in 465 BC,
both Xerxes and disaster crown Prince Darious were killed by an official named
oughta. Bannis the circumstances are somewhat unclear.
Some sources say that the politician first killed Derrius and fearing the wrath
of Xerxes arranged for the King's death.
As well as to say that Audubon us first had sexy skeletons made it look like
Derrius was responsible and Scottish executed either way.
The Kings other son Artaxerxes ascended to the throne of Persia and upon
discovering the treachery of Autobon us Hadden and his sons all executed.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button, please. Also don't forget to check it off.
Fantastic sponsor curiosity stream I'll link to below. Thank you for watching.